varieties 10 problematic films that need
disclaimers and discussions before and
after watching
and they're now on skype uh skye
sorry in this list dirty harry
forrest gump indiana jones and the
temple of doom
me before you once upon a time in
hollywood which only came out last year
yeah uh and then children's hour the
searchers so they're from the 60s
forrest gump 1994 dirty harry 1971
indiana jones 1984. i think that one was
a
was problematic because it showed hindu
people as being the
ones that can take your heart out uh so
yeah i mean
this it it's the circular firing squad
though but i'm always talking about now
culture
is going to be cleansed and when people
do this
there's a way it's also competitive
right there's a way there is a way of
attaining status by doing this by taking
the scalp
you get to brag and say well look i just
aided the revolution
you know we are slightly closer to the
social justice future because indiana
jones has been censored
because head on a spike exactly head in
the spike and
and this taking things down becomes
competitive sport
you know everyone's looking at everyone
else getting kudos and thinking well i
need to do something you know i found
something
and so these campaigns will intensify um
until someone just says well look i just
don't agree that this is a problem
really if i'm the one that's controlled
like no it's not everyone's terrified
yeah and rightly so like the the silence
is deafening stuff so crossfit i don't
know what you've seen that the crossfit
ceo
put his foot in it in a really really
huge way they hadn't i didn't they
hadn't decided
to put out a message when every other
company was
during that period that like five day
period they didn't do that the black
message with white writing
um they didn't have one of those and
then greg glassman the ceo did a thing
tweeted um there was a little bit of
nuance to it
when you dug in deeper but it was ju it
was just a stupid tweet like and
when you think of the current
environment it was
as as basically as stupid as you can get
and
now he's resigned and that is that has
tumbled out there's no way that that
wasn't going to happen
there's no way that i wasn't going to
happen and you know from my side i think
yeah he [ __ ] up like see you later on
greg like you're off mate
but there has to be a line somewhere
with what we do with culture and with
what we allow in from history
people that [ __ ] up right now i'm like
look mate you're an adult
you know but you can't judge
the situations of history by the
standards of today
however yeah you you wouldn't because it
would be irrational to do so
it's like the searches made in 1956
yeah should that be condemned for it
okay no that shouldn't that should be
taken down
okay let's roll the clock forward at
what point
does doing a thing which today is
reprehensible but back then was
acceptable
become do you
recompense in the now because no one's
going to the people that made the
searches in 1956
and saying we need your head on a spike
let's get rid of your blue tick on
twitter
yeah but okay so at some point where the
children's are in 1961 or
indiana jones it was the guy in indiana
jones harrison ford harrison ford
harrison ford's head's not on a spike uh
harrison ford isn't really responsible
you'd think they'd be going after george
lucas for writing it yeah but my point
is like
yeah there's but they will there's a
there's a line
somewhere and i just want i want to try
and work out where that is because once
we have something
definite something a guideline that you
can work with you can be like okay
i can respect the boundary that has been
set
i can ensure that there is a rule
whereby
we do not make people in this in this
world feel uncomfortable but for as long
as there isn't a rule
you can pick and choose that's good
that's bad that's good that's bad
joe biden says in one sentence that it's
racist for trump to not uh let chinese
people in and then two months later
says that the lockdown started too late
yeah like
multiple things being true at once is
yeah i think i think
that the desire to find consistent rules
is uh in in some ways foolish
because it it comes i'm not trying to be
insulting or anything i i i spent years
struggling with that too right um it's
it's
and and so i you know i was foolish to
think teach me expedite
expedite my progress through yeah well
once you realize that they're going for
revolution
you realize okay well revolutions are
effectively wars
you know you're talking strategy and
tactics disposition of the troops on the
field whatever the
whatever the field the battle is you
know it could be magic the gathering or
something
you know dungeons and dragons you know
or playing card games or you know video
games or whatever
it could be hollywood movies whatever
the field of battle is you've got
uh people who are more powerful than
others and
and they they make moves and
your side wins your side loses and once
you realize that and it all of social
justice
requires power to be defined with it
what's racism it's power plus privilege
right that's
uh power plus prejudice sorry um that's
that's not the definition of racism we
use but that's the social justice all of
these words are defined contextually in
a schema
of power um and once you realize that
you realize that
there's no point trying to be
uh morally accurate in to what you've
already said or to your own principles
right
um because you're not trying to
establish fairness
you're trying to win you know so if
something's benefiting
my side yeah right yeah in any direction
i mean
it's not it's not any cost they do have
they do have
limits to things that they'll do and
they won't do but those limits are way
outside of the boundaries of what
someone like you or me might find
acceptable
you know burning down business small
businesses that's totally within these
limits
you know but uh you know insulting a
trans woman
of color on twitter that's totally out
of limits that's not going to do it you
know
so they've just got very different
standards um
what's going to say harrison
[Laughter]
no the the the battlefield uh right yeah
so
this is why you see joe you know joe
biden can say one thing when it's
advantageous for his team and then
the complete contradictory position when
it's advantageous for his team
and none of his team will call him up on
that it doesn't matter mate that
that blows my mind the fact that you can
help someone who can reverse their
position
say a thing and then within months say
another thing these people are supposed
to be the leaders
of public opinion the pinnacle of how we
deliver
the will of the people to the the upper
echelons of the most
powerful country on the planet how on
earth
is that allowed to happen because it's
the great and good doing it they're the
ones with their fingers on the levers of
power aren't they like
it should be the sort of thing that
people scream from the rooftops
like these aren't elected
public officials but it's like how is
there not how does this allow you to
trust and that's not me to say
trump's any better you know trump trump
says trump's got a myriad of failings
but trump is not a revolutionary he
doesn't want to overthrow the american
republic
he doesn't hate the founding fathers
he's not going to tear down any statues
he's not going to do any of he's not
going to defund the police
you know he's not going to increase drug
and crime rates you know things like
like trump has got so many failures but
being
in favor of the concept of the system
is not one of them you know he's he's at
least on that
whereas the left hate the system they
hate what it is how it's founded in
their view
and so they they're going to do so much
more damage than trump would ever even
conceive of doing trump like again like
trump
actually seems to care about fairness as
stupid as that sounds
uh when charlottesville happened and he
was like look
i'm not talking about the nazis even
though cnn always cut that bit out
but on both sides of the argument there
are good people that's a
fairness issue you know if he if he
wanted
he could have said yeah the the proud or
sorry not the proud boys the um
the nazis charlotte phil you know the
protesters did nothing wrong
antifa did something wrong if he wanted
it would look terrible you know a
fair-minded person would like hang on a
second
you know they're both bad at this site
you know and that you know
it's not just one or the other and so
when they when the media when cnn when
the democrats say all evil lies in the
opposition
you know that they're not playing for in
in the ideal of establishing a fair
uh playing field or or how's it not not
just playing field just atmosphere
a society that's fair
you